vanessa
is with us in fort lauderdale florida hi
vanessa how are you
hey dave and anthony how are you guys
great what's up
uh so our association is
having us or acquiring us to repair
and seal our driveway we've got a quote
for that job to be done for
about a thousand five hundred dollars
we're on baby step number two so we are
really trying to
make sure we don't spend any money we
don't need to
um so that we can pay off our debt
quicker
um and and my husband he wants to extend
the driveway
okay he wants to extend the driveway and
we've got to quote for that
and it's going to be 3 500
to extend it um so i'm not sure what you
would recommend my husband thinks that
it's a good idea to just pay the three
thousand five hundred dollars
extend it it's going to be better in the
long term
and i say that now let's just do the
minimum if the association is requiring
us
to just patch and feel let's just do
that
and so i want to know what you guys
think how much
how much debt are you all in right now
on baby baby step two vanessa
so we have a total of 20 000
in debt that includes student loans and
credit cards how much have you paid off
so far
we've paid off
i would say at least two thousand
dollars
we just started recently yeah you
started he didn't yeah
yeah what's the household income the one
that got me on here
he's the one that got you on what on
dave ramsey
and then and then he wants to do
something completely perpendicular to
what we teach
um so our household income is about 80
000
a year yeah yeah okay well you're
you're new to this and apparently he's
um
a little bit new to it too uh because
the whole idea of baby step
two is beans and rice rice and beans
matter of fact i'm probably going to
tell the hoa i can't do the work right
now
yep cause we're broken in debt we're
trying to get out of debt since we get
out of work we'll do the work
as soon as we get out of debt we'll do
the work just tell them not right now
and if you end up having to do something
you do the 1500 you certainly are not
going to do an extension to your
freaking
driveway while you're in debt come on